have you listened to the new idols yet
yeah so good i love them so much and i
was waiting for somebody
to give a [ __ ] and so great
great going greg smith great start
you're the best they rule
um so getting into black box there is a
lot of like interesting cutting-edge
kind of psychological
technological theories ideas being
pushed in this
and i'm curious what your reaction to
all of that stuff was when you first
read the script and if there was
any process of research you took to kind
of like get your head around it
uh what what what in particular are you
talking about
well for me the kind of central idea of
the two central ideas of like going
within your subconscious to find
memories that you've forgotten and then
eventually the more like elevated
idea of uploading or putting a
consciousness into another human
um yeah technology's frightening yeah
it's frightening man um well to stick to
the
to avoid the spoilers i'll stick with
the the former
in um in just one forgetting memory or
just like
just complete memory loss to that scale
that frightens me i mean because it's so
possible
or like personality shifts as a result
of a head trauma
um and just like kind of being lost in
your own body and
in your own supposed life i i found it
very
easy to empathize with that sensation
somehow but um
well not somehow um
it's it was very well well written um so
yeah and that low simmering rage is
something that i think
a lot of people can certainly um relate
to these days
considering what's going on in the
states and globally so
yeah no kidding um what were some of
your
both more emotional and maybe even
technical
tactics toward performing this condition
with
with accuracy with uh with empathy as
you find out it's like
it's just not something that's ever
happened before as far as we know
yeah um you know that was just a lot of
conversations with emmanuel and making
decisions based on our own imagination
um trying to find um something that
didn't feel like a leap but also kind of
tracks throughout the entire
movie in a way that's not like you know
um contrived
but um feels rooted in the reality of
the sky's circumstances so
yeah this is a bunch of conversations
and like even maybe testing certain
things out like hey do you think this
works even on the day
and then finding out because the
camera's right there it's not just an
idea it's like oh we're doing it
so yeah it was that was a fun process to
discover with him this is his first
movie his directorial feature debut what
do you
enjoy about working with first time
directors you can't
really replicate that experience i mean
i've been fortunate enough to work with
like very excited directors
like throughout my career like people
that have like a lot of ambition
but also a real sense of humanity
and they love their vocation i truly
love their vocation like i don't know if
i've seen i mean and i've only met colin
trevorrow
in regards like you know us working in
this movie together
um and in pre-production when we're just
talking about it but uh
dude is so happy on a set even though
like no matter how many hours how many
days
back to back to back he's working he
works throughout the weekends as well
just like it's
you know so that's exciting but like you
only make a movie for the first time
your first time you know um so like to
share that experience with somebody and
learn with them
um you can't really replicate that
experience
and emanuel is just such a
i don't know how he did it in 19 days in
particular
it's just like yeah i know man that's
what i'm saying that's what i'm saying
like what like that's hard for anybody
level on your first feature and like it
has like genre elements to it it's like
it's a mammoth undertaking and he handed
it like a
like like i don't know it was brilliant
how did the two of you uh work together
on those black box sequences the sort of
the compressed hypnosis plus sign
sequences what was that what was that
technical process like
oh well there was a lot of calm response
you know
because i didn't know exactly what a
manual
thing because you know you don't you
only know until you see the movie
and sure there's like a description but
there's he was very specific in
in terms of what he wanted to see in
that in that particular regard because
it is quite technical
and it is a space that he was he had
already created in his mind
and already started developing with you
know the people that kind of create it
in terms of what she sees in the movie
so
that was very specific um
and yeah that was because but the fun
thing about it was
as as he gave more direction the clearer
i saw what he was talking about
like what he what he was going to
eventually put on camera so
were those scenes shot on a set or were
those green screen
yeah we were on a studio set like it was
just like this dark room
you know and then and then like when you
got into the uh
the actual memories those were sets yeah
you know tell me everything about your
working relationship with amanda
christine who plays your daughter
because she she's such a star
and the two of you together are so like
endearing and heartbreaking
what was it like working with her how
did you all approach that relationship
well again like we didn't have much time
to like you know kind of build anything
into her credit she came in ready to
like
ready to work ready to play like you
know and
she's like you know i watched a rough
cut of the movie a couple months ago and
i was like how old is amanda really
you know because she's she's
she she displays like not just talent
but skill
yeah beyond her years yes it's
fascinating there's this one shot near
the end of the movie where i'm driving
away
and i see her from my rear view mirror
and the look that she gave me i was like
we got a reminder i was watching my
girlfriend i was like we gotta rewind
the what
what it's crazy because that's a 25 girl
at least she's incredible
that is incredible and the fact that he
did in 19 days wow um
what were some of the yeah what were
some of the like that the most
kind of down to the wire moments of that
shoot
oh man our last shot was something
um yeah that was something we had to
pick up and
that certainly was down to
the wire
like i was like oh that's that's that's
it that's it that's uh oh we can
okay we can do another one great yeah
that was crazy man but um we got
we got it done we got it done and again
so emanuel's credit is you know
everybody has to be on point but he also
like you know staring everything so yeah
doubling back to colin trevorrow
uh i assume you're in the uk right now
working on
a little film called jurassic world
dominion yeah
uh how is that going what's it like
being in the dinosaur
bubble so to speak yeah it's awesome man
um
learning a lot in this set um because
i've never done anything
remotely like it i've been on a couple
sets now i'm starting to feel
comfortable
you know i was starting to feel
comfortable with like knowing what's
happening
and there's there are things that i
don't know how they're doing
it like and this has nothing to do with
dinosaurs or anything it's just like
filmmaking
filmmaking expertise between john
schwartzman his crew
and colin trevorrow i don't i'm like
like sometimes i just
i just hold my head and like how what
i don't i and it pisses me off that i
don't understand
you know what i mean ah
anyway wow i'll figure it out one day
yeah but i i bet you will um what's
if anything can you tell us about the
character you play
can't tell you nothing not one thing not
a thing
i figured it is a much worth a shot uh i
get it
like i'm not rolling dice you know what
i mean i get that don't want to come out
snake eyes
or dino eyes i guess um is there
anything about like these sequences
you're seeing that are
mind-boggling you is they're like the
smallest teas the smallest hint
that we can be excited for well like i
said like
the filmmaking uh things that are
impressing me so far
like beyond like my understanding it has
nothing to do with the dinosaurs
it's just like what they're doing
with just like the way they're doing the
shots and
i can't wait for people to see it
because it's
yeah uh shifting gears a little bit uh
speaking of your idols shirt
um you got a couple of uh
like hip hop centered rolls under your
belt we've got
you literally play grand master flash in
the get down
you're in patty cakes it's this kind of
like all sort of like soundcloud
odd future leaning sort of
artist what would you say is your
relationship with hip hop and and how
did you tap that for these roles
i you know yeah i guess i guess um
bastard
was a dj yeah he's a dj but like you
know
he's that's not where he started he just
kind of landed
on that because he's like a kind of
multi-instrumentalist yeah and
vessels required for his new friends and
he wants
friends you know but yeah grandma's
flash
i'll tell you what i learned a lot i
didn't know a lot about that heir of
hip-hop and i'm really
i was really blessed to get to learn
from people like
flash himself he taught me how to dj for
that show it's
yeah you know it's one of those things
i'm like oh no but who how many people
can say
that like it's such a gift um and he
also taught me a sense of rhythm because
i had not
really like he taught me how to like
land on the 24 and i didn't i was the
worst person in the past
everyone was better than me everyone
like
i think baz could pick it up faster you
know what i mean like everyone's better
and he didn't even like work on it yeah
you know
um yeah so
and then but just also outside of the
practical
um the history of it the history of it
that i i feel like had been
like you know forgotten in a sense and
you know just
hearing like what the lyrics you know
because there's like there's all kinds
of like
rap music out in hip-hop that um you
know that's underground that you don't
hear a lot of today
in in in terms of mainstream and it was
just kind of nice like
you know go back to the roots and see
like how it started and then you know
kind of track
what happened up until now it's
fascinating
did i answer your question though
because i think i said a lot of things
but i'm not sure if i answered your
question
you said a lot of things and i would say
you answered my question all right
you're on the twos and fours
um what's tom hanks like
um i you know what i didn't spend that
much time with him but like he's the
nicest guy
i met him at the premiere very briefly
yeah he was just so kind
um and i and i like what he's kind of
stands for at like
you know how engaged he is in politics
today and
yeah he's a great guy as far as i know
um and i think james
poncello would say the same he's great
yeah awesome that's kind of what i
wanted to hear there is a big
shift in who this character actually
becomes and i'm curious as an actor
you kind of become almost like a blank
vessel that
other people can go into and i'm curious
what your sort of tactics
techniques how did you approach both
versions
of this character so to speak really the
character nolan i only
play him for like
in the very beginning of the movie and
the very end of the movie
the rest of the time i'm playing thomas
um
he just doesn't know he's thomas the
majority of the movement playing one guy
who has uh who thinks he has a brain
condition and then he remembers exactly
who he is
and exactly what he wants um
so yeah that that kind of was like oh
really i played
uh nolan for a total maybe a minute
you know and the rest of it is just like
how does this guy go through life
thinking he's someone else
but he's really this other guy um and
then also though for that one minute
that i do play nolan like how does this
how's this guy more distinct uh
and because he's just let's face he's a
nicer guy
you know i mean he's just a much nicer
guy and like i
you know i i approach his character with
a lot more tenderness
whereas uh nolan thomas
is kind of uh approached with like he
he's
he's frustrated constantly even when he
remembers who he is he's frustrated and
he's like he's
he's upset um because he doesn't have
any control
i think that's a big thing for him
whereas nolan that's not his like
objective his super objective it's he's
more about like a kind of a love
you know yeah um so once you go from
there then it's just a matter of
decisions
based on the script and talking of a
manual so it's pretty
simple you know yeah it still requires a
lot of work
my interpretation of the ending moments
for you were that
nolan gets to live his life with some
sense of normalcy that he's back
is that how you interpreted or played
the scene and do you think
there is a world where thomas comes back
a black box too so to speak
i don't think there's any designs for a
black box too but in terms of
how the man uh goes forward and lives
lives his life i don't think anybody
could forget that that happened
you know and i don't think his
daughter's gonna forget that ever
you can't forget something as traumatic
as that especially what goes on in his
head
you know he's fighting for his life
literally
like every day um once against like that
black box territory and um
you know does he like find a way to
survive and get through it i'm sure but
like does he still have to like
live with that kind of thing yeah
hopefully you know gets the appropriate
amount of therapy which would probably
have to be constant right you know
i mean imagine you in that situation
you're not forgetting that
no never i would i would like to see a
horror movie sequel where
our main character just goes to therapy
and like
learns to be a better person what do you
think hey listen
sign me up that's good that might be
dumb
all right i'll send you something uh
thanks so much for your time it was
great chatting with you
likewise man likewise